don't get me wrong the newer greedier
version of Batman is fine and all and I
definitely miss the endless stream of
Robins bizarre catchphrases from the
1960s holy uncanny photographic mental
processes holy priceless collection of a
trust and smooth holy interplanetary
yardstick oh oh let me try one uh holy
Robin focused online conspiracy theory
video Batman did I did I do it right
[Music]
holy film theory internet welcome to the
show where we lay our investigative
cards on the table and the Joker's are
always wide sleeveless segue alert Joker
the Clown Prince who needs no
introduction and seriously when I say he
needs no introductions he literally
doesn't need any introduction there are
just some things that don't need to be
reacquaint Batman V Superman plus I
already talked about him plenty of my
theories around the release of Suicide
Squad last year which if you haven't
washed them yet you totally should by
clicking that I icon in the right hand
corner and after doing all that research
and getting myself super amped up to see
the movie and prove my theory the Joker
was in like five minutes of it my
theories were 5 times longer than the
amount of time that he actually ended up
in the movie I mean I guess I should be
counting my lucky stars since that five
minutes at the full two minutes longer
than Jimmy Olsen lasted in the entirety
of this extended universe miss lane
Jimmy Olsen
[Music]
but still kind of a letdown
in fact from my perspective the most
interesting part of this new DC EU Joker
has come from the fans nay the theorists
you see bad before Suicide Squad hit
theaters hacked even before Batman V
Superman hit theaters online theorists
were guessing that the Joker wasn't
quite who he said he was that he wasn't
just some off the street criminal
mastermind like he's been in every other
cinematic incarnation but that he was
instead Batman's favorite Boy Wonder
Robin Robin who had somehow been
transformed into a psychotic madman and
for those of you who think you've
already heard this theory well stick
around cuz I think you're gonna be
surprised by this one now as far as I
can tell this fan theory started
gathering evidence with a reddit post
from Jason G 169 back in 2015 who
started analyzing all the promotional
materials around both of these movies
and legitimately there are a lot of
weird coincidences here the bird tattoo
on Joker's arm the way Joker holds his
cane in the Suicide Squad poster being
similar to how Robins suit is positioned
holding his Lance in Batman V Superman
two bullet holes in the Robin suit
hanging in the Batcave matching strange
dots on Jared Leto's shoulders and promo
shots for Suicide Squad and the fact
that in the video game Arkham Knight one
of Batman's former Robins has a scar of
a J on his face left there by the Joker
a scar that just so happens to be in the
same placement as the tattoo the Joker
has in Suicide Squad legitimately when
you look at all that evidence laid out
there's a fair amount to go off of but
then the buzz kill train named David
Ayer director of Suicide Squad whoa
rolled into the station and killed the
theory dead when asked what the most
outlandish thing he'd heard about the
movie was he responded with this that
the Joker is Jason Todd really it ain't
the case know if you're not a Batman
superfan let me catch you up Jason Todd
in the comics is one of the three main
characters to have taken on the mantle
of Robin over the years and I say one of
because just like there have been
multiple Joker's so - have there been
multiple Robins you have the original
Dick Grayson who eventually moves on for
being Batman's sidekick and turns into
the hero Nightwing Jason Todd is the
next Robin at least until the Joker
kidnaps him beats him with the crowbar
and blows them up in warehouse there's
Tim Drake who tries to alleviate
Batman's depression about Jason Todd's
murder by becoming the new Robin it's
also worth noting that all three of them
have at one point or another in the
comics turned into the Joker so the idea
of one of these characters turning into
a chatot out Juggalo isn't as absurd as
it might seem turning into mr. J is like
a rite of passage for the Boy Wonder
right next to stop crime and a green
speedo in the comic The Dark Knight
strikes again Dick Grayson is fired from
being Robin and becomes the Joker Jason
Todd after getting killed in a death in
the family by the Joker gets resurrected
via Lazarus Pit because hey if he got a
pit that'll revive your dead well you
use that thing upon his return he takes
on the role of the villain Red Hood
which just so happens to be the Joker's
original criminal identity and then
there's Tim Drake who in the 2000 movie
Batman Beyond return of the Joker got
himself kidnapped and brainwashed by the
og Joker who then implants a microchip
into his neck that mutates his DNA to
make him into a joker clone he is
literally a werewolf except for hair he
has white clown makeup and a killer
laughs killer laughs
get it look I'm not saying that all of
this makes a whole lot of sense just
that it's a thing that canonically
happens in this series like every other
month - the Robin character but still I
know what you're thinking why am I still
talking we already heard David Ayer -
bunk this theory so outside of my love
for hiding under comforters in the
middle of hotel rooms in New York City
because I'm recording this on the road
why am I wasting so much time recording
this thing well listen again to what he
said it ain't the case he's not notice
that David Ayer didn't say that the
Joker wasn't Robin he said that the
Joker wasn't Jason Todd but as we just
went over there are at least three
different Robins and when you actually
look at all the evidence put together
across the DCE you the much more likely
scenario is that this version of the
Joker is actually Tim Drake Robin number
three so get ready as bat Pat straps on
his utility belt we haven't a moment to
waste so quick to the theory mobile
let's start with Suicide Squad and
project Cadmus Cadmus labs is a
fictional genetic engineering company
that appears as a recurring threat
throughout all the DC properties for
instance throughout the second season of
the show Supergirl there's a recurring
plot line where the organization led by
Lillian Luthor mother of Lex Luthor
tries to eliminate all aliens Dirk
next category circles but there's the
live-action Green Lantern film you know
the one that DC desperately wants us to
forget we're a Cadmus facility gets
attacked until the CG I wonder steps in
to not only save the day but also save
the head of the program
and a walnut you heard that right amanda
waller the master strategist behind
forming an anti superman task force
comprised of a guy who shoots good a guy
who climbs good and a girl who bats okay
and though project Cadmus isn't
mentioned by name in Suicide Squad
you remember those nano bombs that
Amanda Waller plants and everyone's neck
yeah well in Batman Beyond we learned
that the Nano chip implanted in Tim
Drake's neck by the Joker was originally
developed by project Cadmus to create a
clone a Batman once the Dark Knight got
too old for the job and the person in
charge of that prototypes development
none other than Amanda Waller
what doesn't outright prove that he's
the Joker it does prove at the very
least that we're dealing with similar
timelines and similar universes for both
Batman Beyond and the DC Cinematic
Universe now of course for all this to
work we need a scenario in which Jared
Leto's version of the Joker had lost
complete touch with his true Tim Drake
identity before he converted to the
Joker and wouldn't you know it but
Suicide Squad gives us that exact same
scenario one of the Joker's first
sequences in Suicide Squad is when he's
got Harley strapped to the gurney and is
about to electrocute earth skull
let's see what he has to say in this
moment you help me by erasing my mind
erasing his mind oh you left me in a
black hole of rage and confusion
so the Joker doesn't remember his past
he doesn't know where he came from I
don't know about you but that is pretty
darn suspicious but you see just how
suspicious let's pull in some science
here you see what the Joker's
referencing here is known as electro
convulsive therapy
better known as electroshock therapy a
treatment with the unfortunate side
effect of patients having trouble
recalling events that occurred during
the weeks leading up to the treatment or
even the weeks
after treatments in more extreme cases
they can't remember their wedding days
the fact that they have children huge
chunks of their past now we know from
what few lines we have in the movie that
the Joker and Suicide Squad does indeed
suffer memory loss as a result of his
ECT treatments and we know that Harley
Quinn is the one responsible Horrocks
but why if Harley loves our puddin as
much as she says she does why would she
put him through a treatment that would
erase all his memories the simplest
explanation would be that she's trying
to make him forget something specific
about his past something like say the
fact that he's not really bad Joker if
anybody could pull off this trick it's
Harley I mean don't forget she is a
trained psychiatrist so she would know
what she's doing with the
electroconvulsive therapy and if you
paused the opening of Suicide Squad just
at the right time you can actually read
her rap sheet only to learn that she has
a history of using false stories to
manipulate the men in her life so the
fact that she's a quote accomplice in
the murder of Robin could just be her
killing Tim Drake's true identity
reprogramming Robin with electroshock to
convince him he's something else someone
else the Joker it's also worth
mentioning that in Batman V Superman you
have these very ominous voice over lines
playing while batfleck is looking at the
Robin suits twenty years in Gotham I
meant good guys are left
I'm gonna stay that way how many stayed
that way don't know about you but it
sure seems like the Batman of this
universe has watched his fair share of
good guys turn evil and playing that
line over the footage of the Robin suit
with Joker's scroll all over it makes it
seem like this concept of a good guy
gone bad is somehow related to both of
those characters here's a bombshell
foria potential Robin candidate number
one
Dick Grayson he's already dead before
the DC EU even starts at the beginning
of Batman V Superman we watch a burial
scene for the Wayne's
ah spoiler alert Bruce Wayne's parents
died I'm so sorry I am so so sorry I
should have warned you anyway you see
that gravestone back there you know the
one next to the angel well if you zoom
in a bunch of times and enhance it you
see that it says Richard Grayson for
1982 died mm dick is a nickname for
Richard in case that's confusing anyone
and Dick's dad's name is John so it
wouldn't be his father either and if you
think all of this is completely
unbelievable this evidence was actually
confirmed by some set spies who went out
to the graveyard where they shot this
scene and took photos of the gravestones
photos that just so happen to be
promptly removed by Warner Brothers but
of course not before the internet made
like a gajillion copies so weird that
Warner Brothers would choose to kill off
the character who would eventually be
Nightwing and kill him off while Bruce
Wayne is still a child
absolutely but then again look what
cinematic team we're talking about
Batman is branding criminals Lex Luthor
has hair and remember Jimmy Olsen
getting shot you know Jimmy Olsen one of
the most beloved characters from
Superman's canon well here's what Zack
Snyder had to say about why he did that
one whoa we just did it as this fun
little aside because we had been
tracking where we thought the movies
were gonna go and we don't have room for
Jimmy Olsen in our big pantheon of
characters but we can have fun with them
rights and quotes fun fun
by killing him off on ceremoniously and
what do you mean no room for him there's
plenty of room for granny's exploding
peach tea there was time for Jolly
Ranchers but no no there's no room for
Superman's best friend Jimmy Olsen it's
just just very
telling that this is the way the
creative team behind these movies see
these characters in the lore around them
needless to say the DC EU is treating
established comic lore in a very fast
and loose way so the idea that Dick
Grayson could be dead at this point not
that big of stretch which segues nicely
to the main complaint I've seen people
make about Joker equals Robin theories
online Jared Leto and Ben Affleck aren't
different ages in real life Robin would
have to be a whole lot younger than
Batman to which I say to you guess what
else they aren't in real life
superheroes martial artists criminal
masterminds it's a movie it can be made
up to be pretty much any age and
seriously when you do the math the age
ranges line up very cleanly to suicide
squads Joker being Batman's former
Protege in Batman V Superman we hear
Bruce say he's been batmanning it up for
20 years 20 years in Gotham - and a
producer for the movie confirmed that at
that point in time he's in his mid
forties that means he started being
Batman when he was 25 canonically this
is in alignment with the comics
meanwhile Robin in the comics joins up
with Batman a year later so Batman is 26
and Robin is 12 so 20 years later Robin
would be 32 and Batman would be 46 Jared
Leto's Joker absolutely seems like he
could totally be 32 but you know what he
doesn't seem like he totally be older
than Batman you see people usually think
of the Joker as older impulse Tim
Burton's original Batman film as well as
the Batman TV show the Joker was around
10 to 14 years older than Bruce but
those admittedly do funny things with
the lure so we should probably turn to
the original source the comics though
it's never officially mentioned we can
make our best guess based on the clues
to the characters origin Joker's design
was based on the design of a character
from the movie the man who laughs the
resemblance is actually uncanny now in
that movie conrad veidt the actor was 35
and since the character is pretty much a
direct rip we can assume the same is
true for mr. J considering that the
original Joker falls into the bat of
chemicals that permanently disfigured
him shortly after Batman's first
appearance
and Batman was 25 when he started we can
assume that the Joker is again about 10
years
other than baths is it a hundred percent
set in stone well of course not but it
does reinforce the idea of the Joker
being older than Bruce Wayne and say
what you will about Ages but Jared
Leto's Joker doesn't feel older than ben
affleck and certainly not fifty-six
which means he could very well be a
younger generation of Joker a second
round a clone a boy beaten and kidnapped
in his late teens then reprogrammed to
be the Clown Prince by the og Joker and
then brainwashed by a Harley using
electroshock so based on everything the
bird tattoo the scars matching the suit
holes the memory lost the connection to
project Cadmus David Ayer rejecting
Jason Todd as a candidate Joker's
missing backstory
Bruce is ominous lines from the trailer
the characters history of turning into
the Joker and the age timeline to me
there's a strong case to be made for Tim
Drake being quote-unquote killed by the
original Joker and reprogrammed as a new
one by Harley and while the logo on the
Robin costume could certainly work for
either Tim Drake or Jason Todd it's the
clue hiding in plain sight that makes
Tim the obvious choice here for a Robin
who's been converted the weapon you see
each Robin not only came with their own
tragic backstory and eventual excuse to
start wearing clown makeup but they were
also differentiated by their signature
weapon stick Grayson's Robin became
Nightwing and used two electrically
charged billy clubs pretty sweets but
not a match Jason Todd never really used
any significant weapons during his time
as Robin so no bueno there but Tim Drake
well wouldn't you know it he just so
happened to use a staff case closed
yeah probably not it's probably just a
bunch of coincidences or at most
creative ideas that got left on the
cutting room floor by a creative team
who are too scared to execute on stuff
like this but heck if it doesn't make
watching these two movies a whole lot
more fun and when it comes to these two
movies anything that makes watching them
more enjoyable is a welcome addition to
the lore but hey that's just a theory a
film theory holy end of the episode
Batman
heyyou strong masculine dark and
brooding Batman fan listen up do you
need more pink pastel in your life are
you looking to impress female folk by
showing you're sensitive to their needs
are you looking for something to fill
the empty void in your life after
adventure time comes to a close well if
you answered either yes or no to any of
those questions boy do I have a series
for you three words bee and puppycat
it's kind of like you've adventuretime
had a baby with Steven universe wow that
sounds like a baby I'd love to
binge-watch
well you can find its newest episodes
exclusively on Verve huh whoops looks
like someone forgot to buy a vowel verb
is a new and more importantly free video
streaming service that allows you the
chance to discover more content from
creators that you know and love all
while supporting their newest creations
and it's made by the team over at
crunchyroll so in addition to getting
awesome stuff like cartoon hangovers
bravest warriors rooster teeth's Ruby
and Adam Savage's tested because damn it
that Mythbusters money is gonna start to
run out and a brilliant TV host slash
engineer needs to eat VirB also gets you
access to all your favorite anime like
attack on Titan season 2 and Naruto next
generation late there's there's a next
generations of Naruto since when it's
called roots Oh way to get creative on
the naming there guys you get all that
stuff Sumter dubbed in 1080p HD on
pretty much any device that you want
Roku PlayStation Xbox just not the Wii U
since you had your chance Wii U you had
your chance and you wasted it wasted it
desktop even your mobile phone thus
making it the perfect entertainment for
a long summer day spent in a hammock or
a long summer night spent on the toilet
all that corn-on-the-cob ain't agreeing
with me but look he gives me the excuse
to watch a full season of Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood or Funimation's
absolute classic Akira
oh yeah and let me emphasize that once
again it's free
but hey you watch YouTube so you're used
to that sort of thing or you can just go
to www.hsn.com Idul of an ad which is
kind of ironic but whatever click the
link in the description Verve co /
matpat link is below spend your summer
catching up on all that anime you should
have watched by now or at the very least
all the awesome animation and nerdy [ __ ]
and that's coming from all your favorite
creators from these platforms just
remember that your free download of
Verve today will help ensure that Adam
Savage TV host and engineer will eat for
another day now anyway if you'll excuse
me I need to start researching big game
animals of the African plains I will be
seeing all of you guys next week
[Music]
you